ben altri ragazzi e benvenuto questo no
io sono un fan di j e oggi siamo tornati
con quadri che si è gentilmente prestato
per un secondo video non pago di aver
sbagliato le risposte sulle mie stesse
canzoni un po deciso a fare domande su
di me che secondo me se ci urla può
essere tanto però una classifica dei
losers
grazie a dio no lo tengo io per comodità
ma rispondi tu quanti iscritti a 3
milioni e milioni solo perché questa
domanda è un po vecchia però ce la
passiamo non di più lo so come si chiama
la mamma di famiglia e quasi azzecchi ci
sono dei problemi perché non puoi sapere
non ha però visto tuo passano alla
chitarra non servendo un grande evento
però
laura ci sono i problemi e dai solo ai
tutti sapete il nome di mia madre leder
che lavora joe è solo è laura j aria
joey non la regione si è mai fatto
crescere la barba ma nostri nome è
possibile c'è un problema proprio di dna
di genetica
ho provato una volta ma anche con la
barba non so non sembra neanche un
essere umano quando è nato fa vj qua mi
riprendo con la domanda sui tuoi anni
dall'ultima volta dunque 90 96
96 potrai mi dai venti giovani di quanti
mancini avrebbe effettivamente sembra un
po un sedicenne quante persone sono
state necessarie per uccidere l'insetto
che fa vj ha trovati in marocco questo
sono sicuro che la sai la sai questa la
sala visto come video 20 volte sicura
posso chiedere l'aiuto del pubblico ma
secondo me non lo so neanche il pubblico
che lo chiediamo pubblico lo sai a caso
a caso che abbia caso cioè 3 ma che culo
marra resiste ma da era mai credi male
anche mario ci avevo scuro non si posso
ma se ci riprovi un miliardo di volte
non riesci di nuovo va da sé che la
passiamo come si chiama il cugino di fa
vj questo nel mio cugino chi cazzo è
questo
matteo matteo ma chi è questo non ho mai
visto in vita mia te lo giuro morea 3g
ha mai fatto kingdoms ho mai fatto
kingdoms com'era quello non devi
ascoltare i nostri consigli 6 quale
kingdom e questo gioco che stai facendo
in questo momento è proprio qui è
proprio questo gioco quando lotito sul
sito i fan con chiamato abbia volta in
due azzurri spiegami come faceva sapere
che mi stanco ma sa cos'è successo nel
video della tavola witia dopo che lui ha
detto la fase iniziale l'esperimento a
tavola vice serve per evocare gli
spiriti
siamo sulla terra è partito l'antifurto
dove ha abitato lorenzo è stato vestito
bene milano e torino il 6 prima il re di
torino so perché di torino e diamo
concittadini non cittadini che come si
chiama l'alieno che fa vj ha vinto ad
aggiungere questa perché stava lino di
libri quindi solo che il mio blu e
arancione a me guarda non so se è giusto
ma c'e un sacco alieno della minkia gesù
per la dinamica secondo me era meglio la
non so perché non ci ho pensato
parigi ha paura dei
la mano tu non mi suggerisce sbagliato
sto suggerendo che lavora dei pirati era
la paura noi stessi rom ai pirati non
stessero mai pionati dei muffin ma come
faccio per favore infatti quando entrò
da starbucks mi sale l'embolo quando fa
vj ha mangiato questo telecomando una
data ben esclusione non puoi dare guarda
i miei capelli e diane di esclusiva il
seggio infatti del 2013 e 2014 fra il
real che avrei risposto 2013 ha rapito
venisse la partita d'addio poi niente
era partito con laura sul cuscino a
forma di pan di stelle regalato da
giorgio quante stelle ci sono nove
quante stelle ci sono su un pan di
stelle già da allora secondo me ce ne
sono 11 forche norma e ho detto il posto
io sono un po io sono coerente anche se
mi volevi sviare veramente c'è una 11
mila quanti bisogna fatto di the forest
questa una delle mie serie di puntini di
mediaset
no aspetta se avrete tutti io 10 sai
quanti pd che fa tutto di robot
highsmith pronto il solitamente di keane
che giorno usciva alfa vi risponde è un
blog quindi in che giorno escono i blog
sabato a lui sabato in realtà non fa non
vale discoteche ma guarda i favi
rispondere questo video canali me vegas
come si chiama lo stava montando non per
questo aspetto è un auspicio mi sono
fatto verde si non era quello di
cavalieri fragai non solo a risposta le
mie domande vi giuro io vado tranquillo
ma in torniamo le saprà in meno di lui
non lo so ora che non sono un buon fan
di farisei non ci fa molto bene come si
chiama il bambino che a volte appare nei
suoi video sul ritorno lo scriverei
perché la j è sempre presente nei miei
video in chiami ha incontrato allora io
mi chiamo fa vj perché ho incontrato una
volta un giocatore su world of warcraft
devo guardarmi rubare il tempo che
era prima che tu facessi m2o signore
servizi 2004 non era neanche lato un
altro po
avevo già noi di parigi è bravo ragazzo
è bravo ha studiato allora abbiamo fatto
la domanda sulla madre come si chiama il
padre di famiglia
vai gabri suonato la tu sei alla
chitarra quindi si offende un sacco
dello sbaglio ma time ai divieti che li
fa parte della mia famiglia non lo
sapevo già non è possibile per giorno è
nato fa vj questa secondo me non lo sai
siamo figli di pitagora e di fa aprile
ludico per il nostro aprile ha suggerito
non va ma che 10 o pesce la sostanza
manco stanza dove nello speciale di
quanti iscritti ha fatto ladro mylife
razza che rai mai ma se la zeki aggira
sul palco in mutande ma io direi 45
minuti facciamo stasera sul palco in
mutande piazza del popolo la rai a un
passo avanti ma amo faccio si vabbè raga
io lo sono molto più ferrati sulla
famiglia ostuni che si munisce di me
questa cosa è un po strano ragazzino
ringrazio gabry per aver partecipato
anche questo secondo video vi lascio
all'altro che sempre fatta da lui io mia
figlia di grazie ancora cambi di corsia
ragazzi di vivere un momento non mi
chiamo la misura perché d'appartenenza
sera visti discutere ci vediamo un po
seguito da ragazzo
[Musica]